>> The value at which the frequency is highest is called the mode. And this
certainly works in describing the distribution. In the case of a histogram, the
mode would be this bin right here, and this bin right here. The most common
value is the mode. And, in this case, we can't see individual values, but we can
see that most of the values rest within this bin. So, the mode occurs here, and
here. The value in the middle of the distribution is called the median. And this
would also work. We'll go more into depth later. And finally, the average is a
statistic that rests at a specific spot in the middle of the distribution. We're
going to elaborate on this in this lesson. The value where the frequency is the
lowest, in this case, it's right here. And it looks to be about 72 or 75. And
this most definitely would not represent the whole distribution where there are
a lot of scores here, more towards 50. And the biggest value on the x-axis,
again, that's here at about 75. Here, probably the biggest value is somewhere
around 90. And that doesn't represent the whole distribution so let's ignore
these two. But we know that the mode, median, and average can all help describe
the distributions. They each have strengths and weaknesses, and we'll explore
all of these throughout this lesson.